-Our next guest
is a prolific writer,
legendary filmmaker
and Academy Award-nominated
director of more than
70 features and documentaries.
His memoir, "Every Man
for Himself and God Against All"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Werner Herzog.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Werner.
-Thank you.
I like to be back here.
-It is wonderful
to have you here.
I'm so enjoying
reading your memoir.
But when you write a memoir
and I have a question
uniquely for you,
what is Werner Herzog's
relationship with the truth?
-Well, when you go
into the memoirs,
you have to verify
what's -- what happened.
So, and some people
are dazed and confused
because I live such a wild life
as if I had lived five lives.
But I sent the manuscript
to my brothers
who are very critical,
and they said,
"Yeah, okay, go ahead."
And then people doubt, "Yeah,
did he move a ship
over a mountain?"
Yes, I did. It's documented.
[ Laughter ]
Did he hypnotize
an entire cast?
Yes, I did. It's all
in a way verifiable.
For example, there was doubt --
I staged an opera once in Italy
and I wanted to have
some stage work
falling from high up
and through the stage floor.
And everybody is wondering
what the hell happened here.
And and the theater
wouldn't give me a stunt man.
So I tested the stunt myself
from something like...
[ Audience gasps ]
Something like 45 feet down
into an air cushion.
And so people say I made it up.
No, I didn't.
There are a series of photos.
I can show them to you
or whatever. I was --
I was shot during an interview.
It sounds like
"Yes, he made it up."
No, it's caught on tape.
It was a BBC interview.
So you better be careful
when you do something like that.
If you write poetry,
you just invent.
If you write fiction,
you invent completely.
But here, of course, what is an
inventive element is the style,
the way I'm telling the story.
The wild sort of content
needs a certain style.
-And there is, of course,
a lot of documentary evidence
about the things
you've done either on film
or just in photographs.
You chose the photo
for the cover of this book.
This is you on the edge
of a volcano.
-Right.
And I had a protective suit.
-Yes. But I noticed you took off
this protective part
for the picture.
-Yeah, because it was
at the end of it.
I was with a volcanologist,
and the volcano was spitting out
slabs of glowing
hot sort of lava,
and it came raining down.
You'd better look up.
Where does it come?
You don't duck.
You have to look and step aside.
So, and we were too close.
And all of a sudden,
some unexpected burst
and it came raining down.
And some of these slabs
or blobs,
thousand degrees Celsius,
they come raining down.
So you better run.
You get out of there.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I don't mind
to be a coward in such a moment.
-But it did seem in that moment
you also said,
"Should we get a picture?"
[ Laughter ]
-I don't recall, but no,
I never asked for a picture.
I'm not so important.
The film is important
or the writing is important.
But I had taken off my helmet
because I was sweating
and I had soot
in my face somehow.
And actually this photo
was done
by the volcanologist,
Clive Oppenheimer.
He had his photo camera
and he said, "Stand still.
I take a few photos."
And I kind of like the photos
because my life has been on foot
digging in the jungle
and moving a ship
and doing things like that.
-You talk about how -- and this
is fascinating to me --
you can see a whole film before
you start writing it sometimes.
And you talk about
writing "Aguirre, Wrath of God,"
which is this movie --
It's hard to imagine
conceiving this whole story
and sitting down to write it.
But when I pictured
where you wrote it,
I would never have guessed
it was
where you said
you wrote it in the book.
-Well, it was written
in two and a half days.
I saw an entire film
and I was on a bus
with my soccer team
and we went to Italy.
We had two huge barrels
of Bavarian beer for our hosts.
We tried to make them drunk
and win the game.
So but what happens,
our team started to open
a bottle -- a whole barrel,
and they were drunk
within two hours.
And I was sitting at that time
a little typewriter on my knees
and writing the screenplay,
and even my goalie
leans over me and he says,
"What are you doing?"
Then vomits over my typewriter.
[ Laughter ]
So what can you do?
I threw out a few pages
from the window
and I forgot what was on it.
I forgot.
So I had to type on
and I wrote the screenplay.
I don't need a quiet island
where I'm all alone
and things are serene.
I can write
on a playground for children
who are throwing toys
at each other and scream
and the dog is barking at me.
It doesn't matter.
I can write any place.
-You wrote something
very funny in the book
that I would really
like you to do.
You wrote -- You were talking
about seeing the auctioneers
at a livestock auction,
and you wrote,
"I always wanted to direct a
'Hamlet' and have all the parts
played by ex-champion
livestock auctioneers."
[ Laughter ]
"I wanted the performance
to come in at under 14 minutes."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
Well, still -- still
unfinished project.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, you know,
these livestock auctioneers,
they speak with a speed
that is unimaginable.
For me, the last poetry
of capitalism, so to speak,
and I really want --
anyone knows
basically what's happening
in "Hamlet."
And I want to bring it down
under 14 minutes.
-Yeah.
-Unfinished business.
-There you go.
Well, you have a lot.
And I would like to --
There's a film you did
that last time you left,
I so regretted -- and I'm a fan
of so many of your films.
But "Bad Lieutenant:
Port of Call New Orleans,"
you mentioned
in the book as well.
It is again a career
of fine performances.
It might be my favorite
Nicolas Cage performance.
And you concur.
-And Nicolas Cage
had been interviewed about it.
"What is your favorite
performance?"
And he says, "There's one,"
"Bad Lieutenant" with me
and then there's nothing
and nothing
and then comes the performance
that won him the Academy Award.
I think "Leaving Las Vegas."
-"Leaving Las Vegas." Yes.
-Yes. And it was so wonderful
to work with him,
such a -- such a great,
great actor.
And I loved every minute
with him.
And it was wonderful.
-Well, it shows up
on the screen.
It is a fantastic film.
-It shows.
-Yes. It's a fantastic book.
And I know you're
as prolific a writer.
You've already
written another book,
which means you get to come
back here again soon.
-Okay. Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
Werner Herzog, everybody.
"Every Man for Himself and God
Against All" available
wherever you buy your books.